so I guess the big news that's uh just
dropping Kanye West is being sued for
250 million dollars because he said
George Floyd died due to a fentanyl
overdose you cannot defame the dead so
this seems like a stupid waste of time
but I guess what they're going to be
arguing is that accusing George Floyd
having died from fentanyl reflects
poorly on the work being done by the
family and so I suppose in that regard
they're going to try and loop this
around and be like look we're trying to
be activists and be political and the
story of George Floyd matter so they're
actually defaming us I don't think it's
gonna fly but we'll talk about that plus
as just you know Kanye's in the news
Elon Musk is in the news it looks like
the Twitter deal is about to close
Twitter has locked the accounts of their
employees or they can't trade shares
which sounds like they're getting ready
for this deal now that that was uh you
know a story that's just breaking uh
very very uh around now
recently and uh we were we were planning
on talking about initially which is why
I'm a little was uh a 32-point swing
from Independent Women from Democrat to
Republican in like the past month a
major shift something happened and now
you've got these ridiculous Joe Biden
coming out saying we're going to codify
Roe v Wade even though it's not a top
issue for voters the economy is and
you've got Eric swalwell putting out
what may be one of the funniest
satirical parody bits I've ever seen a
woman eating dinner with her husband
when the police come to arrest her
because she got an abortion but it's
just like so poorly done it looks like
an SNL skit so we'll talk all about that
before we do my friends head over to eat
right and feelwell.com click the link in
the description below and pick up your
C8 MCT oil powder from BioTrust keto
Elevate again eatrightandfeelwell.com
the keto diet uh it works wonders I mean
talk to your doctor nutritionist about
what's right for you but if you're
interested in doing this trying to lose
weight or just get healthy check out
biotrust's MCT oil powder I like putting
in my coffee it's actually really good
it's not too unlike creamer and many of
you may have noticed if you watched the
John Stossel interview with me that just
came out recently I was I was more
rotund a supportly fella and I lost like
30 some odd pounds really fast no joke
it was like in the span of a month when
I cut out the sugar and started going
keto head over to
eatrightandfeelwell.com and you'll get a
60 day money back guarantee keto Elevate
provides your body only C8 the most
ketogenic MCT that means it provides
support for energy levels healthy
appetite Management Mental Clarity and
focus athletic performance how do you
think I work so much rent five grams of
the highly sought after mctc8 keto
Elevate personally it's my favorite I
really do like it you'll get free
shipping on every order and for every
order today BioTrust donates a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kidhungry.org to date BioTrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
Hungry kids please help them hit their
goal of 6 million meals this year you'll
also get free VIP live health and
fitness coaching from bio trust team of
expert nutrition and health coaches for
life with every order and their free new
e-report the top 14 ketogenic foods with
every order it says new but I mean I
shout it out every month so unless it's
like being updated again EatRight and
feelwell.com Shout Out BioTrust thanks
for thank you for sponsoring the show
and also head over to timcast.com become
a member directly by clicking that
beautiful join us button to support our
journalists directly you'll also get
access to the uncensored members only
show we have one coming up tonight at 11
PM where we talk about issues that are
not so family friendly and can get a
little bit spicy but also
we have a new episode of the cast Castle
Vlog up tonight starring two amazing
guests rusty cage and Blair white so
you'll definitely not want to miss this
one it's at timcast.com it's probably
gonna get a lot of people really angry
so I'm really excited should be um I
don't know some people might be offended
by it but it's all it's all jokes it's
all it's all jokes Blair was fantastic
Rusty Cage was hilarious so I'm really
excited for this episode of the cast
Castle Vlog we're we're getting there
we're ramping up making things better
and better and of course we have a bunch
of other shows so don't forget to smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us today to talk about all of
this and more is Amin Bundy
thanks for having me I'm excited to be
here you sound like it huh yeah it
sounds fun so uh who are you for those
that aren't familiar so I live in Idaho
I'm running for governor in Idaho and um
but mostly I'm a husband a father
uh I grew up on Iran so it kind of got
famous in 2014 the Bundy Ranch and uh
a lot of things happen there that maybe
we'll talk about absolutely get a chance
anyway so there was a standoff with the
feds yeah I believe there yeah people
went to prison yeah my family been
ranching there for well now 150 years
wow and uh federal government came in
and basically said that we couldn't do
it anymore they wanted to make our Ranch
a mitigation area for the desert
tortoise
and uh my dad wasn't willing to give up
his rights and so he decided he was
going to take a stand and
it got a lot of attention
internationally and here in the United
States
and that kind of
kicked me out of my little comfort zone
and ever since then I've been fighting
and standing up and helping people and
now I'm running for governor right on
well we'll talk about uh we'll
definitely be talking about that that'll
be interesting so thanks for joining us
absolutely we also got the T-shirt
salesman himself I have so many
questions this is going to be a great uh
podcast hey guys I'm here to be more
anti-government than our anti-government
guest my name is we are change.org and I
come here with one very simple message
regulate your government not your
neighbor if you agree with that message
you could get the shirt on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
do that's why I'm here thank you so much
for having me uh I will be playing
statist on the show tonight the
left-wing uh guy that wants to you know
talk I'll be the authoritarian I'm just
kidding good to see you man you guys
going to come over the table at each
other yeah most likely we'll roll around
we've been meaning to work out together
anyway so I think it'll be a lot of fun
and I am here representing Idaho voting
for you Mr guy there you go all right
well let's just uh jump into this first
story check it out from Yahoo George
Floyd's daughter announces 250 million
in dollar lawsuit against Kanye West and
then it says the mother of George
Floyd's daughter announced they are
filing a 250 million dollar lawsuit
against Kanye West over his recent
statements about Floyd's death the
rapper who goes by yay erroneously
declared on a podcast that Floyd died
from fentanyl not as the result of
police brutality now you see I love how
they say he erroneously declared uh no
Kanye defiantly declared he was
basically saying I don't agree with your
assessment that it was police brutality
now the official Coroner's report says I
think it was the police action and there
were contributing factors which included
heart disease and uh drug use the report
actually showed I believe
that he had fentanyl norefentanyl THC
methamphetamine in a system and and uh
nicotine as well yeah nicotine so he's
smoking cigarettes there's five drugs
yeah wow and I guess the report was that
he was chewing on a speed ball which is
like meth and Fentanyl combined or
something is that what it is I suppose
cocaine and heroin I think combined but
in this case we fentanyl oh okay so
apparently he was like chewing on it and
then he spit it out or whatever I don't
know so look this is Kanye West's
opinion he's allowed to have one he
watched a documentary it's ridiculous
that you can sue for that I mean you can
sue a ham sandwich doesn't mean you're
gonna win Kanye's comments are repugnant
attempt to Discount George Floyd's life
and to profit from his inhumane death
attorney Pat D Dixon the third sent a
statement on Tuesday adding that the
goal with the lawsuit is to hold Mr West
accountable for his flagrant remarks
yeah he also had covid and a lot of
people were pointing out uh particularly
Jack was hoping that he was also
unvaccinated so he was like take that
leftist oh yeah but but again this is
just an opinion and and I think you know
we I was kind of talking about the story
on my program yesterday and I'm like
this could be the The Alex Jones
president that has been set here as
we've seen Alex Jones has now been sued
by the family members that that he uh
criticized to the tune of one billion
dollars and uh I I think this is going
to be an important verdict that I think
they're going to be playing off in this
particular court case to try to stifle
people from expressing opinions that
they don't like and it's just crazy you
know where's Free Speech where's the
First Amendment we should be able to
exercise our ability to say whatever we
want
so Tim is it all right if I just set
this one out I don't really want to be
sued here okay is that okay all right
I'm totally joking now I mean look the
mother of George Floyd's daughter I
don't what what's that
well I guess confused here there's no
baby mama yeah that's what I'm thinking
yeah something like that'll be George
Floyd's baby mama is that is that I'm
trying to make sure I got his girlfriend
though they weren't official no like
baby mama meaning like someone you had a
kid with yeah right so so the
appropriate term would be baby mama yeah
I think that's that I think you're right
anyway I was just kidding about setting
this one out well you don't want to get
sued we could all get sued by you know
what we say here today because if this
is I'm not I don't care I'm actually
being sued right now by uh St Luke's for
defamation Hospital yes oh no way oh
because I stood for uh family where they
were involved in taking their child uh
through a CPS case and I I rallied a
bunch of people and and we got the we
got the child back to his parents
and then later St Luke sued me oh wow
for defamation so look I mean it was not
it's not it's not quarter million or a
quarter billion dollars but hey quarter
million yeah
250 million oh yeah Alex Jones they you
saw that story right 965 million dollars
that's the meme now like whenever
someone's caught lying you just say like
I demand 965 million dollars no a lot of
people need to understand like he wasn't
just ordered by the judge to pay 965
million it was like 50 million for this
family 60 million for this family 40
million for this family and I'm like
where do those numbers come from you
know is it like what what's what's the
true cost of you know let's let's say
everything they accused Alex Jones of
doing is like true and legit like how do
you get the 40 million dollars and for
that matter Kanye West goes on some
podcast and he goes I watched a
documentary by Candace Owens and it said
this is what really happened and now
he's got 250 million dollars
you know fine set the precedent because
I got a bunch of lawsuits I could file
against all the fake news and you know
what if they want to play this game each
and every one of you can sue all the
fake news outlets for every lie they put
out yeah let's do it I'm glad we're
revisiting the George Floyd stuff
because it really concerned me the
amount of drugs he had in his system
according to one Coroner's report there
are two Coroner's reports one the family
had done and they said he died I believe
it was asphyxiation that brought on a
heart attack the other one said it was
just a heart attack that killed him and
then you look at the drugs in his system
they said that he had levels of fentanyl
that were intoxicating meaning he was
high he was behind the wheel of a car
when they pulled him out he was
screaming if you see the second video of
him screaming at the cops that were
dragging him like trying to control him
to to take him out of the car put him on
the ground he's like put me on the
ground put me on the ground I'm gonna
die I'm gonna he kept screaming I'm
gonna die I can't breathe I can't
breathe he was screaming before they
ever put any knees or anything on the
guy like he was struggling he was in a
bad State I think he was freaking out
because he's just been doing a speed
ball and he was behind the wheel of a
car felt like he was going to go back to
prison or go to prison
um and he and he he the whole Terror
thing really pushed him into uh
I'm not saying the terror killed him but
you know Panic can cause people to die
you know your your heart can stop
um for things like that so yeah this is
important to talk about here's here's
the ridiculous thing PolitiFact says
Floyd did have Fentanyl and his system
at the time of his death as West said
however the Hennepin County Minnesota
medical examiner ruled the cause of
death was homicide due to
cardiopulmonary arrest
uh pulmonary arrests complicating law
enforcement sub dual restraint and net
compression experts in toxicology
Cardiology and drug use stated death by
overdose was unlikely or impossible
so what we're dealing with is Kanye West
watched a documentary the real lawsuit
would need to be pointed at the daily
wire good luck with that because here's
how here's how the the stupid system
works I gotta admit it it's a relatively
stupid system uh a news Outlet can
publish a lie about anyone here
and then let's say let's let's just
hypothetically say NBC News publishes
publishes a false statement effect ABC
then sees it and reposts it
NBC the original story deletes it and
says whoops we were wrong but now it
still exists on the other outlet and if
you sue them they'll say we cited a
different website so you have to go
after them they'll say we already took
it down then 800 000 other news outlets
will will go to ABC and copy what they
wrote and there is nothing you can do to
get that stuff taken down absolutely
right yep
what do you got your power outlet was
that me again yeah but AC hump yeah
there we go yep thanks man it's also
important note here that that Kanye or
yi whatever whatever he wants to be
called Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah
from now on also donated two million
dollars to the George Floyd family a
couple years ago and it wasn't enough
they want more he's a compassion they're
doing them for 250 million I mean I I
you know these cases are just frivolous
and it shows you how people are being
punished for expressing wrong think
that's not a society that is free that's
not a society that of course could allow
freedom of speech where's and again this
is something that that should be
important you could express any opinion
but because people get their emotions
hurt they could throw you in court and
waste your time and money that's just
crazy man Money Talks man so is this
because indefinite defamation cases uh
there has to be some way to prove that
there was uh like a loss of income or
something to that damages I mean mean
what are what what are they claiming
like you know I don't know maybe this is
just uh a PR thing it's going to get him
a bunch of attention they're going to
get the it's a virtue signal it's going
to get them the the we're the good guys
fighting back against you know crazy
Kanye or whatever or they hope that he
has a a bunch of money he'll just settle
with them they'll get a few hundred
thousand dollars or something like that
uh you know maybe but but I also kind of
think he's the kind of guy who's going
to be like he's going to go to a lawyer
and just be like here's a million
dollars have fun yeah you know when
you're a billionaire like that you don't
really got to think twice about it if
Kanye had to pay restitution to these
this family would it be taxed to the tax
restitution payments you guys know I
don't know actually they might not
because it's like a donation he could be
like oh and here's an easy way to donate
another 50 million to this family if I
want to
oh yeah that's a good point I don't know
I think I actually talked to the lawyer
about this and I'm not I'm not I'm not
exactly sure maybe people in the in the
chat might know better but yeah that's
an interesting point because if you say
you cost me a million dollars you got to
pay me the million dollars back the
argument is that you're already negative
the million dollars so it you know what
I mean like if I'm negative a million
bucks you give me a million bucks I'm at
zero you know yeah maybe that's the
argument I think this is really an
example of piggybacking off the Alex
Jones trial that we just saw where where
they they people that weren't even named
in yeah we've got a buzz we're trying to
figure out where that's coming from it's
not on my end though it's not mine it's
unplugged um where people that weren't
even named by Alex Jones uh for the
definition
all right there you go um people that
weren't even named were suing Alex and
for defamation which is very odd because
normally if you're not named publicly
then I don't I don't see what what basis
you have or standing you have and that
billion dollar settlement is like now
people are feasting they're like oh
anything anybody said about me that
hurts my feelings I can maybe get money
for just never describe people you know
like you just just never identify
someone in any meaningful way
so like uh what did I say the other day
that everybody I said something about uh
annoying white liberal women on Twitter
you know who I'm talking about and then
everyone oh yeah I know and I was like I
I just said Annoying I don't know I
wasn't referencing anyone in figure but
everybody seemed to have someone in mind
so there you go that annoying white
liberal woman on Twitter you know I'm
talking about she is the worst she kicks
dogs it's like I didn't say I who did I
put who am I accusing I'm not you know
non-descript if someone changes their
name to white liberal woman can they
retroactively Sue
all those people that went to Jeffrey
Epstein Island all of them they're all
bad they're all bad I don't know though
actually there's an interesting strategy
in defamation like
you know Luke if you were to call out
any one of those people who went to
Epstein Island and you say is a
statement of fact they did a thing they
might be able to sue you and you can say
oh no I'm being sued time to go to
Discovery show me all the communications
you've had with Epstein everything done
on the island and could potentially open
it up to be like okay let's see what you
got and then you get them under oath in
front of a lawyer and you can ask them
the question directly so strategic love
fair I guess I you know I think there's
there's pros and there's cons if you
have the time and the money though to
deal with it you know because you're
right you get sucked into the courts
and they just drag it on for years and
years and years you know you you're
paying an attorney you have to go to the
hearings it's just you know and I
someone someone like
West doesn't matter you know he's he has
an attorney does it do it but if they're
going after you know
people who don't have the funds and or
the means to be able to defend
themselves it becomes quite a problem Oh
you just lose instantly yeah people
really you really don't understand this
I mean if it you you can be just
outright shut down if you get sued and
you can't afford a defense like what do
you even do so now you have to have an
attorney to uh for free speech right to
be able to speak how you want to speak
you have to have an attorney there
backing up and a couple hundred thousand
dollars to defend yourself
yep
Money Talks for-profit lawfare I think
that's a problem yeah oh yeah I mean but
but lawyers provide the service I've
talked to a bunch of lawyers about a
whole bunch of other issues and there's
there's varying degrees of issues where
you know I've been defamed and they'll
say there's no there's no standing here
sorry you have no damages and then
they'll also say I mean you can sue them
and you know it's just lawfare basically
yeah where it's like someone defames you
know they defamed you but they're
protected by the precedent times V
Sullivan meaning you know you need
actual malice or you can't prove damages
which is I I think that's absolutely
insane because then you end up with a
hundred news outlets all just trying to
destroy your ability to fundraise but
then how do you prove it was their
statements that stopped your ability to
fundraise so I'm thinking about like
project Veritas how often has it been
that project Veritas has has lost a
donation because of defamation how do
you know are you gonna go fine You're
Gonna Knock on the dorm back ma'am do
you ever heard of us okay would you have
done you would have donated to us but oh
you saw ABC well there we go now I'll
write that down that's damage no there's
no way to find those people so I think
there's pros and there's cons here I I
actually think
the solution to this should be
if you get sued like if you sue someone
for defamation the immediate there there
should be a were you damaged by this and
if so upon proving fault the individual
should compensate you for the damages
however if the damages are ill-defined
in either context you should be forced
to issue a correction stating the facts
so if Luke said something like Ian once
you know threw a jar out the window and
then Ian proves it wasn't or Ian then
Susan says prove it and Luke can't then
Luke would have to be like I have no
evidence to support this claim or you
know in the in the instance it probably
needs to be a bit more specific than
that but my point is if someone says I
did a thing I didn't do and it's it's
provably false I should be able to sue
them to force them to publish a
correction prominently to to rectify the
damaged reputation because it's not just
about money it's about reputation in the
long run and then what happens if
someone defames you and the damages
don't come until a year later you know
it's just there's got to be a way to
solve for this because the media can
just keep lying about everybody and
getting away with it
well yeah that's what they do that's
their motive Opera operator modus
operandi wait is that it yeah it sounds
Latin yeah yeah it is well there you go
let's talk politics now that we talked
about Kanye West we got this story from
Vanity Fair how scared should Democrats
be about the midterms I'll just jump
right to the bottom and I'll explain
they say even if you ignore the eye
popping 32-point swing among Independent
Women the new Republican lead it shows
tracks with other recent polls simply
put for some reason in the past couple
of weeks almost all of the polls have
shifted from Democrat to Republican and
now it's looking like if you if you add
that together with the the bias in the
polls as it is Red Wave red tsunami so
uh are we excited are we secretly
laughing because we know that
Republicans aren't actually going to do
anything if they do win where are we at
with this yeah I'm um I don't know if
excited is the right word but but I'm
satisfied with the change in politics
also changing geographicals I've been
just watching maps of like countries
changing over the years and like people
I think have this idea that borders are
stagnant borders constantly have changed
throughout history and I think political
affiliations political parties new ones
are created old ones go defunct uh Tulsa
gabbard left the Democratic party I
think it's inevitable that that thing is
I mean as people wake up and see that
the the fascist business collusion with
the Democratic party it becomes kind of
apparent that it's not the good guys not
that the people are bad I think a lot of
the people involved are just involved
because they always have been but you
know that that system is pretty busted
up looks like from the outside so is it
more than just the women or uh you know
is it a full shift there's a full shift
across the board but but a 32 point this
is one poll by the way maybe it's just a
bad sample size but among independent
females 32-point swing I mean that's
it's insane yeah I think that so it was
it was plus 14 Democrat and then a
couple weeks later plus 18 Republican
wow and I think it might have to do with
schools but I really do think it just
kind of comes down to gas prices yeah
yeah Joe Biden got caught in a quid pro
quo with Saudi Arabia and then people
were just like I'm sick of it and then
you're running what are you seeing on
the ground what what are your people
telling you about the projections what
how are you seeing this political
landscape
yeah well in in Idaho we have
this struggle between what we call
conservatives and Republicans because
everybody in Idaho is pretty much
Republican right literally and so like
the the Deep State The Establishment
well they're Republican well and the
conservatives who want freedom and want
you know want the good things of life
and want this country to be free well
they're conservatives but they're also
Republican and so that's what we're
seeing like kind of this battle of
establishment Republicans versus true
conservatives and uh it's it's it's very
interesting and the you know the mothers
have a lot to say about it they're
concerned and I don't know if this is
you know nationally why this poll is so
uh so uh
strong when it comes to women but you
know they're worried about their
children they're worried about their uh
you know they're worried about the
future of their children you know that's
constantly on their mind I'm sure they
don't like paying the five dollar gas
either oh yeah but uh but I think they
have a sense of like if if we don't do
something right now like uh you know if
we don't correct this uh this is going
to get much much worse so there was a
poll where they asked people would you
vote for someone who denied the election
and Democrats overwhelmingly said no and
Republicans were kind of split I think
it's funny because the Democrat
perspective is Trump and so they just
think they're ragging on Trump but if
it's like okay what about Hillary
Clinton she denied the election several
times she still does to this day and
then they're like oh well you know what
uh but I think it's funny because
ultimately the poll found is that no one
cares no one cares about this stuff they
they're they're they're going to them
and saying like January 6th even
Saturday Night Live was making fun of
the January 6 committee and they called
Adam Schiff the uh a villain from the
horror movie smile and then he was like
we're not even unless somebody has to
say he's too spooky and they just skip
over him I thought that was funny just
ragging on the guy but hey there you go
the January 6th stuff is so unappealing
that's that Saturday Night Live thought
making fun of it would actually do well
for them and it did although they did
make a joke that you're you're either a
republican who's not watching it or a
Democrat who's nodding so much your
head's falling off but then they they
they mock Chuck Schumer mercilessly and
Nancy Pelosi so you know it is what it
is but I think the reality that they're
that they know but won't let go you know
nobody who's voting is voting because of
this I mean look maybe a handful of
people are like we better we better save
our democracy but I guarantee you
you walk down the street and you say who
are you voting for they're going to say
republican why gas
okay that's it end of story economics is
always the
seems to be the number one reason uh why
power shifts from one party to the other
yep yeah all right how's your how's your
race going particularly like who are you
running against what's the biggest
difference between you and your
competitor so I'm I'm running against
the Republican incumbent
um Brad little and he's you know the The
Establishment guy there the Deep State
um if you will and uh kind of a rhino
yeah he's absolutely a rhino you know
Idaho was the we we look at Idaho and I
think the rest of the country looks at
Idaho and says hey you know they're
really conservative they're kind of uh
you know
more far right however Idaho was the
first state to arrest pastors for having
church outside during covet wow and we
were we we were the first state to
arrest a mother for going taking her
kids to the park uh you know and it was
all done under Governor Little's
lockdown orders and so you know I mean
the difference is
you know completely different I don't
believe the way he believes I don't
believe that that's the purpose of
government I believe the purpose of
government is to protect people's rights
not to infringe upon them and uh and
this is this is Idaho yeah this is Idaho
you got people in Oregon who want to
leave Oregon and join Idaho yeah they're
they're you know the highways are clear
full of people coming into Idaho it's
the fastest growing State oh yeah in the
country yeah but you know who it is
tell me well we're hearing a lot that
wealthy people are buying up oh yeah
these wealthy you know ranches and
Estates yeah that's prices are insane I
think they're called Kami fornions yeah
and I think there's also a lot of
elitist buying like Doomsday properties
and farming properties and there's also
one guy who loves to you know Force down
fake meat down everyone's throat who's
also buying up a lot of property
everywhere else what's his name
it's like it's like you know he
represents closing of something closing
of Gates or something like that yeah I
wonder who that is so can we not say
that then on this channel Bill Gates is
a scumbag full disclosure is he I don't
know him I'm gonna stop insulting
people's uh person and start insulting
the things they do yeah there you go
because I have a feeling I'm gonna meet
these people one day you know when Bill
Gates was being interviewed about being
on Epstein's plane and then just went
well he's dead now anyway yeah I was
like wow what a bad guy you know someone
lost their life here you know what I
mean like you know Bill come on
where he even divorced his wife because
of their close friendship together you
were saying he's yeah
I was your buddy man that was your best
friend and if someone's gonna treat
their best friend like that imagine how
they're gonna treat you I just want to
point out real quick that we did the
story about how Bill Gates has
organizations that track mentions of him
uh you know in media so there you go
bill
anyway you were saying what's up Billy
oh man you were mentioning earlier a
difference between conservatives and
Republicans especially in Idaho do you
find that as conservatives that people
tend words toward libertarianism but
that they don't don't adopt the
libertarian party because it's too small
or something uh I don't think that it's
too small I think the issue ultimately
is is kind of on abortion like like they
won't go to the libertarian side because
of abortion and also because of kind of
law enforcement really like they just
love law enforcement no matter what they
do and this would be the this would be
the establishment and the conservatives
like uh but people are waking up that
there's good law enforcement there's bad
uh and that uh and it can be very
dangerous and so I would say if there
was two issues it would be that it would
be you know libertarian view on on
abortion and then also just law
enforcement and their role and and who
they are and what they do so if you
would win the race what's the first few
things you would do what's your policies
that you're running on how would you
change Idaho so one is is abortion I
mean we have this opportunity I am
absolutely uh for protecting life I
believe that life begins at conception
and so I think that we have to protect
that life so number one or at least
that's the first thing I I will do
um and Roe versus Wade being overturned
push it back onto the state so it makes
it a lot easier for me to do that
um we also have like major problems in
Idaho in well in the west because if you
look at a map and people out east just
don't realize this but if you look at a
map east of the Colorado Rockies the
federal government controls 51 percent
of the the land mass and in Idaho it's
61 percent and then they're controlling
72 percent of the subsurface mineral
rights wow and so it's making it so like
Idaho can't even pay its own bills like
we're beholden to the federal government
to pay our bills because they're
controlling all our land and our
resources and so that that battle has to
be fought and I plan on fighting how did
the feds get control of the land so it's
a long long story but this is like the
whole battle that my family was in you
know that that basically culminated in
2014
uh because the states were enabled into
the union and and all the land and all
the resources were supposed to then go
to the state and the jurisdiction of the
of that state but
through this environmentalist movement
and because the air the area is so arid
people didn't go live on it they
couldn't live on it and the federal
government came in later and claimed it
and now they're claiming it as their own
they're saying it's in trust
um and that they never they never uh
they never released it or or disposed of
it is the right word and so there's this
major battle with like families like my
my father my family and my father in
particular where they're trying to
defend their rights and my family my
family's been there for now almost 150
years and the federal government comes
in and says well we're taking it from
you well there's this and that's
happening all over the west and well I
mean but you got to trust the government
right they're they're here sure sure
yeah they're here to help and they're
doing it for you know the right reason
I'm sure you know uh what was it the
tortoise yeah desert tortoise but it
well you got to protect the tortoise
well yeah yeah what is your family for
all tortoise that's right yeah I mean I
mean that's probably why my family
doesn't need to make a living they can
move to the city and and do whatever
they're going to do there even though
we've been there for 150 years have you
considered owning nothing and being
happy I I have a hard time considering
that I just can't see all the work
there's some puffy pods out there though
and you know video games VR they're
they're pretty cool maybe they're the
tortoise how about some bug Brokers
compromise well take your whole family
we'll put them in pods we'll give them
VR headsets that simulate working on a
ranch out in Idaho and all the bugs you
could eat non-stop bugs yeah actual
exoskeletons right that they're that are
bad for us I don't know okay you know
yeah suggestible bug shells so the feds
came in and were like by the way we've
owned this the whole time and you didn't
know kind of thing or what did they
offer compensation no not at all not at
all they no so yeah they did do that uh
which is an absolute lie they they try
to make the people of this country
believe that that that has always been
in federal hands and that it wasn't
disposed of to the state and to the
people and it's just a flat lie well
really what what it was is the West has
just arid like there's you can't have
farms and you can't grow things in much
of the West and so people didn't settle
there and they just came in and said
look at all this land that no one's
living on no one's claimed we're going
to take it but the problem is is in the
west you don't claim the land you claim
like the grazing rights like my dad owns
the grazing rights the logging rights
the mining the mineral rights and those
were like deeded rights with the states
and so here the FED comes in feds come
in and say well we're taking the real
estate and therefore every anything else
that has rights on it we own we control
and it's this huge messed up legal
battle that's going on because my dad
has my dad has grazing rights he has 11
of them deeded with the state of Nevada
and then the federal government comes
along and says well we own the land we
own the so you can't graze here and he's
like wait a minute now that sounds
bunked because I I've been we've been
dealing with with this when we were
moving out to West Virginia everybody
warns you you're only buying surface
rights and then I'm like what does that
mean and that means that if somebody
owns the mineral rights they can come on
your property in a way that's reasonable
and start digging and then I'm like what
what am I buying then like if I'm gonna
build something here I can't even come
on with some machinery and start digging
in my ground yeah so they they separated
that this was all part of this they
separated made it so that you can
separate the real estate the land with
the mineral rights right and that that
wasn't that wasn't always the case
remember the uh Beverly Hillbillies
where they bought this land and they
were digging and this oil comes out next
thing you know they you know they're
Millionaires and they moved to Beverly
Hills yeah well that's the way it used
to be like if you own the land you also
own the resources underneath it or above
it yup but now big corporations will buy
the land buy the mineral rights sell the
surface to you and then in the event
they actually find something show up one
day and be like out of the way yeah up
now to our uh benefit I suppose there's
not really a whole lot going on in West
Virginia in terms of minerals so unless
they discover something they didn't know
about before some new minerals yeah
they're using all the coal gone then
because I thought West Virginia was all
about coal I think that's in the
mountains though like Mountaintop and
stuff like that I don't know for sure
what I do know is that when we were
looking at land we we went over this and
they were like you don't have mineral
rights but to be honest they've already
done a sweep here's the report there's
nothing here it's like mud and rock like
nothing worth anything but there's been
a new breakthrough in underground
scanning with I think lasers and there's
uh underground mapping yeah uh it might
not be lidar but a form of laser
underground mapping so they might start
finding crazy minerals deeper than you
thought I don't know they could discover
something new that's what people don't
realize we may find out eventually that
there's something you know look we think
we know everything we think not
literally but we think we know and then
one day it's like oh hey wait a minute
we need this kind of mineral and it's
not just this you know graphene for
instance we'll use that as an example
yeah what if they just don't want to
mine the carbon they're like oh now dirt
itself is a mineral not that what if
they discover that there are certain
carbon deposits that are more uh that
can easily be converted into graphene
for some reason and now all of a sudden
they call it something like graph carbon
deposits and they say well we didn't
realize this 10 years ago and we thought
your property was worthless but now
fortunately we have the mineral rights
to your property and we found there's
graph carbon deposits so we're coming
and they they can take up to at least in
the at least in the west uh Nevada and
either they can take up to 49 of your
surface rights to to mine or to extract
whatever subsurface but with you guys it
was just about a tortoise well yeah so
we're like What so we're like in the
like the desert desert like if there's a
desert in this maybe the Sahara Desert
is a little bit drier but that's about
it I mean we're talking about the Mojave
Desert like no one wanted to live there
in fact
there was a group of people what are
they grazing on what are the cattle
grazing just like there's like there's
shrubs there's you know some and certain
times of the year it it'll rain and
there will be grass
um you know they they have to struggle
from from yeah you know and then we have
these Waters because they're spring so
we have Waters all around where they can
they're just little Springs but we
capture the water so they have water
troughs and they don't have to travel so
far
but that area was like 150 years ago no
one wanted it like the people that came
in before my family
they they went back and reported to
Brigham Young and Salt Lake and said
that the place was uninhabitable right
and then we went in there a few years
later and started you know making a life
out of it and a living out of it and
then now you know for whatever reason
well we know why but uh they you know
now now people want it and uh was there
like uranium or something oh yeah I was
going to show you this uh I don't you
know I don't know if you but the real
reason the real reason is quite obvious
of what what they want and when you look
at a at a map of the federal control
I'll just show you for for the fun of it
right you all right with that oh is it
is it is it definitely minerals of some
sort so this right here is that's a map
of of the the red is federal controlled
land yeah so you can see the West is
like they own Nevada yeah they've yeah
89 but then what do they want with the
land well this is this is the whole
point so let's look at uh these are the
Mercury and gold mines yeah here we go
it's the same map wow right right and
and like uh here's a uranium
exactly it's the same Mac called it and
that's what that's what they want
they're they're controlling the natural
resources and they want to make people
think that they're doing it to preserve
it why don't they just come up to you
guys and be like here's 10 million
dollars have a nice day because they
didn't think they had to they thought
that they could come in and just take it
because they've done it to to hundreds
and hundreds of other ranchers and and
loggers and Miners and everything else I
mean look they just print the money
anyway they should just walk up and be
like here's 10 million bucks yeah but if
they do it to us you know then they have
to do it to everybody else and they
found a better way they they just run
you out they apparently not now I mean
at the very least they should have they
haven't come to you since then and been
like okay how much do you want actually
uh they they tried that with my dad but
they so the the the Constitution which I
know they don't follow it and why do
they care care but but they actually did
they tried to get the county to buy my
dad's rights and my dad refused he
didn't want to sell them right and so
and and I'll say this though but they
try they can't even offered a a good
enough amount no they offered him
seventy five thousand dollars right
right so which is you know the price of
a pickup right now so yeah exactly yeah
your family's history everything your
legacy your your farm it's gone here 75k
it's like but but it was in the attitude
well we're going to take it anyway so
here this is an easy way out for you and
wow my dad was absolutely no so what if
they came and said two million dollars
would you guys pack up no so no no way
my my dad has been offered for because
he has a lot of water rights like actual
coming down the river too and uh and
private private property there
and so he's been offered a decent amount
of you know millions of dollars and he's
just not he doesn't want to sell I mean
for whatever reason he has his reasons
he's not going to sell has he considered
taking like hundreds of thousands of
balloons and putting him in his chimney
and then flying the house
I saw something about that once that's
crazy it's crazy what what's going on
what happened what was the resolution I
heard that the ranch like The Story Goes
you guys were like no we're not giving
it they came on the property there's a
shootout so
uh there wasn't a shootout but what
ultimately what happened this was during
Obama uh 2014 and he thought he had
enough political power and and he had a
basically an internal internal
bureaucratic Army and he sent that them
down upon my family
um it was the FBI which we didn't know
that at first but FBI Bureau of Land
Management U.S forest Service that's BLM
yeah yeah the other Bureau of Land
before it was cool and they came down
with a 213 Federal armed basically Army
and locked the ranch down
uh they began to kill the cattle from
from helicopters burying them in Mass
Graves destroy the water infrastructure
destroy the corels and meanwhile they
were threatening that this would be
another Waco or Ruby Ridge if we were
resisted yeah so we it took us a while
to gain enough courage to start to like
confront them and stand up to them and
people started coming and then they they
killed your animals yeah they killed
like 60 head and buried them in Mass
with helicopter shooting them with
helicopters yeah I mean this all sounds
like explicitly illegal like they're
committing crimes yeah but that's the
definition of government yeah but
they also claimed you know they were
saying we were trespassing yeah but I
don't think like if if someone's cow
wanted on my property I can't kill it
yeah I don't I mean like the federal
government does what they want to do
yeah all right right they do what they
want to do if it was a bull maybe and
like went on my land and like playing
something yeah but there's like a cow
you know a couple of cow walking by I
think it's no one no no one would find
it reasonable that you start mowing them
down from a helicopter yeah like yo dude
what are you doing especially I agree I
mean no look right now we got the story
with Lauren bobert where the Democrats
accused her of killing a dog and then
like you read for 10 seconds into the
story and you're like oh the dog broke
onto her property it was attacking her
goats then you read it's actually her
other neighbor who killed the dog
because the dog had actually attacked a
bunch of animals and Lauren's like I had
nothing to do with this talk about
defamation right yeah seriously but I
mean in in in that capacity it's like
you know you've got something attacking
your animals you protect your property
to protect your animals absolutely but
that's what not what was going no this
is that this was killing a bunch of cows
they were just killing them burying them
in Mass Graves causing Mayhem literally
and then we started so the interesting
thing is is that they
they set up these areas that they called
First Amendment areas they were like
miles away from the ranch and they were
like these construction mesh you know
the orange construction masks Freedom
cages yeah and they and they said that
if you're going to protest or
demonstrate or anything our actions you
have to do it in there that's your first
amendment area so of course we didn't do
that so they started sicking dogs on us
and tasing us and throwing us to the
ground and doing all this stuff well
people were filming it and they started
sending it all over the country and next
thing you know we got hundreds and then
thousands of people coming you know what
this story reminds me of
Avatar you guys know that that movie
yeah yeah where where the noble true
land owners are minding their own
business on their big tree and the evil
government comes in to steal all those
minerals beneath that tree just killing
everybody that's right yeah yeah that's
the story here the only thing is it
doesn't really work towards their
Hollywood narrative because it's a bunch
of like white ranchers I guess and not
Native Americans yeah that's why we
weren't so popular right uh because we
were just there and evidence colonizers
yeah
well and I I do say this all the time
like I know when I was born there there
was no Native Americans other than other
ranchers there was other ranchers that
were actually Native Americans that
ranched in their Rancier and they were
they were pushed out and driven out just
like by the rest of us yeah well that's
another story about the the colonial
patriarchy government kicking out you
know the honest worker right that's
right yeah it's not it's not a racist
system it's just hungry for money and
resources power and there there's this
um
like
Unholy alliance between those who want
to control the resources make money and
all of that build their bureaucracies
all that power stuff that we know about
and these globalist environmentalists
the green religion and they've like
locked arms in basically coming and
trying to control and drive mankind off
off the land that's oh that's very uh
telling and I think that correlates with
what you're saying about going after the
standards for the tortoise yeah that's
that's why so you've got you know this
the global environmentalists that are
like saying we got to save the tortoise
which it's all based upon lies and then
you have the those who want to control
the the resources the the subsurface
mineral rights and the land and so forth
saying like well come come with us and
we'll
will stop people from using this and
then then they take it for themselves
and that's that's what's been happening
all over the West is it like a tortoise
Haven or something you guys got a lot of
them well
I mean there's there's a lot of there's
a decent amount of desert tortoise down
there but the thing thing of it is is
the studies actually the true studies
actually showed that when there's cattle
there there was more desert tortoise
because the their main staple was manure
right they actually ate the turtles ate
them oh yeah they dig through it yeah
the the cow pies a big they'd go in it
and they would dig it and they they
would Thrive off of it so when you had
more cattle uh you had more desert
tortoise but they didn't care about that
they don't care about them I was going
to say that because
um it seems to me that cattle coming in
it's going to create it's going to
expand the ecosystem that the manure is
going to result in more growth it's
going to it's going to deposit you know
minerals or whatever and then just
result in a more robust ecosystem albeit
still small and desert-like but but Tim
I just want to I just want to talk about
this fact here the US government
literally tested 1032 nuclear weapons on
American soil this is a government that
does not care about any kind of natural
environment or anything that the U.S
military industrial complex the U.S war
machine is one of the biggest polluters
by definition and and of course that's
just being yeah
by the way but why did why why did they
test those nuclear weapons to protect
the tortoise all right they knew that
Vladimir Putin that you know Khrushchev
and Lennon and all those guys going way
back what they were really after the
Soviets they needed to join us they
needed to Nuke the tortoise
in my opinion the federal government
owns 28 of all land in the United States
that is 28 too much in my own personal
opinion and those Free Speech zones are
absolutely absurd and I think they were
ruled unconstitutional they were
originally started by George W Bush when
he was trying to stop protest against
his regime and and his larger anti-war
protests that of course people were
protesting against and they just were
like well you can't really protest but
you can in our little regulated areas
where of course you don't have any
speech at all you're just you're just
cattle yourself which is absolutely
crazy so yeah with the people launching
nuclear bombs on American soil I'm not
going to be lectured about how they need
to be there to save the environment
that's that's bunk that's [ __ ] we'll
come back a little little bit of this
but I want to jump to this political
story here we have a tweet from Eric
swalwell and this might be one of the
funniest bits I've ever seen this makes
Saturday night Saturday Night Live look
like you know amateur improv hour at a
local local College Comedy Club Maga
Republicans want women arrested for
having an abortion this is what that
looks like all right let's play the
video it's got 2.5 million views as of
as of 24 hours ago I hope you guys are
ready to enjoy this
oh wait I gotta fix the audio I always
do that because before the show we
switched the output yeah all right there
it is there it is
foreign
[Music]
yes I have a warrant for your arrest
rest for what penal code 243 violation
unlawful termination of a pregnancy
you've got to be kidding me that that is
my personal business that's for the
courts to decide man your medical
records have been subpoenaed and Dr
Landry's already in custody
no my God you you can't just you will
have to submit to a physical examination
no no no one's touches
[Applause]
put your hands behind your back now why
is this happening
love you honeybear
we're just enforcing the law here
elections have consequences vote
Democrat on November 8th stop
Republicans from criminalizing abortion
everywhere there's more protect women's
rights and freedom
please don't do this
Eric swalwell you know what I love like
in the beginning when he's doing like
near the baby's mouth and then the the
wife is like he's cute and the kid's
like he's gross I was thinking like
the reason why they can't get the acting
right on what a family looks like is
because these people don't have families
yeah so they're just like I think this
is like I also want to point out that
the first reply you can see is from
Adrian Curry shout out people cannot
afford food gas or even their own homes
and this is your strategy LOL no
seriously like the production value is
so bad yo the cops if they ever did show
would be like man we have we have a a
warrant for your arrests come with me
they wouldn't be like you're going to
get a medical exam we've arrested your
doctor they wouldn't say any of those
things right to remain silent anything
is here do can be against you the court
of law please put your hands behind your
back and that would be it and everyone
the husband would be like oh hold on and
then she'd get arrested that's about it
would you be arresting people
oh I look at it like okay there's a
little baby right there uh eating uh and
what if they what if they decided they
were going to kill that little baby
then wouldn't it be just well that's her
personal business well yeah yeah I guess
that between them too right like you
know but that that to me that's how I I
view it and you know the more I look
into abortion and the more I look into
really what it is uh it is murdering
babies that's what it is and so uh yeah
it should be uh it should be enforced do
you think from the point of conception
at any point abortion should be made
illegal penalty prison I do believe I
believe that life begins at conception I
believe that that is the correct
a point in which you would you you would
determinate a life and then that the
state's job is to protect it should the
mother go to prison as well as the
doctor like in this video from Eric
swallow uh yeah uh it's a it's a sad
unfortunate thing and it's going to be
very difficult to try to get like
Society to switch their minds on this
that that it's not okay to kill a baby
um and it's going to be hard uh I think
we've got to be a somewhat uh you know
I hate saying this but you know there's
a transition that you have to you have
to go through but it is not okay to kill
babies I mean if you like the contrast
of this I guess because this really
isn't a great production but just go and
watch I mean it's terrible to watch but
just go watch a video of an abortion you
I know what you need to do you need to
make your own version of this but like
the mom has like a mustache she's
twirling I'm gonna kill this baby
and then the husband's like yes uh so
but no I mean if that's the case
um a lot of conservatives say they would
never go as far as arresting the mother
for this it's the provider who kills the
baby who would be punished not the
mother but you're saying you you think
the mother is involved well I mean if if
Justice was to be served it's those who
had the intent to kill
what about exceptions do you think there
should be exceptions so I think
conception should be termed because
there is the where you have
um
where the baby gets or the the uh gets
in the uh excuse me I'm trying to get in
the Philippian tube and that topic
pregnancies yeah there you go that's the
term uh and that will kill a mother I
think those are considered non-viable as
it is and so those aren't at least for a
long time that wasn't considered an
abortion and then in vitro is another
thing like you know because they're
actually taking the the sperm and the
Egg out and they're uh
fertilizing it if you will and then
they're putting it and so some people
are like well that's conceptionist too
so I think that it needs to be deter or
as part of the definition must be that
it's in the womb there there's
challenges here because I understand
what you're saying and uh Eileen more in
the traditional pro-choice side the
issue I take with it I also view is a
Libertarian perspective in that
it there are circumstances there's
challenges here I'll admit so let me let
me walk through this there are
circumstances where
if a woman does have a legitimate risk
or problem with the pregnancy how do you
get through that effectively does the
state have to get involved and issue a
permit to allow it to happen I mean
these things can become overwhelmingly
complicated and then what what is an
actual Health matter for the mother is
now an issue of the state and
certification or permitting and stuff
like that I I have a I have a hard I
have an issue with that well so I do
understand though just to just walk
through this I think abortion is wrong I
think too many women today are using it
as contraception I think the mainstream
left the modern left is pro-abortion and
that makes there's there's there's no
there's no middle ground for you know
how we actually deal with an extremely
complicated and let's let's be real
there's there is no middle ground I mean
you either are going to create a
circumstance where women will get
elective abortions as birth control even
though we think it's wrong or you'll
penalize the woman or arrest the doctor
or the woman so and that's why you know
I intend on declaring life begins at
conception and making that the point
because ultimately it's
it's a determination of when life begins
because
then you have to say well
then it's not okay to take the life
right I mean if life begins at this
point then it's not okay to take the
life is it you know we all agree that
after the baby is born it's not okay to
take their life right well I don't
believe that that's when life begins I
believe that it begins at conception and
so therefore the state's job is to
protect that life and uh and ultimately
when it comes down to like a court
proceeding or or a trial or a
prosecution it comes down to intent what
about in the case of rape
so
I actually I'll admit to you that I did
at one time believe that that should be
an exception uh but I do not believe
that there is a right way to take a life
I I hear what you're saying I and I I
understand the moral position the
challenge I have in this circumstance
let me pause first because you know
people get content get heated on this
one
um
uh well let me just say we'll get
through this we'll get through it we'll
get through a woman who threw no fault
of her own is raped and forced into
carrying a baby
she did not she was completely
responsible in every right and was
victimized I don't see how the state can
determine that you have to provide your
body to another living person now I I do
understand this is the extreme it is
extremely rare that this is the case in
terms of abortion this is the problem I
have 90 was it 92 percent of abortion is
elective or no no reason give it just
just contraception concept of abortions
that that's that to me is insane
but the issue I run into is the
government being like now I know you
were victimized but we the state have
determined your body and blood now must
be shared with another person so this is
the reality of it though
um the reality of it is is
those who get an abortion suffer more
emotionally in many other ways because
they got an abortion versus those who
actually keep the baby they may turn
they may give it up for adoption
whatever but but they are I mean they
are healed more by having going through
that pregnancy and having that baby it's
it's difficult yeah but that's that's
not that's that's not a legal more or or
moral argument I mean that that I can't
understand I can't understand that
argument I mean if there's a woman who
says you will not the government will
not force me to carry my rapist child
like
you might think she'd be better off but
if she's saying if she's gonna kill
herself again I know the writer that
it's writer that that child to to live
that's that's where that's where that's
where it becomes it's difficult right
because we're talking about a life here
yeah that's why we're saying that
there's no matter just because of the
circumstance that you were you know if
you you were
uh created if you will uh now because of
that circumstance we're going to take
your life and that I just don't I don't
agree with that I think that the the
better way is to to side with life
that's where I that's where I end up
Sheamus uh coglin of Freedom Tunes made
the point I believe it this was the
point you made Sheamus so if I'm wrong
uh uh forgive me but uh he said the
detriment to the female in the scenario
is less than the detriment to taking the
life yeah so so his point was basically
yeah you know you know what this woman
might now have to suffer for for another
nine months but suffering for nine
months is not nearly as bad as killing
determinating the life of another being
I I still run into this I don't like
government and I and I don't like that
idea but but I certainly understand uh
believe me I'm I'm right there with you
and I it's tough huh but man when you
when you watch which is terrible I've
never been able to watch a video to the
end with it
person I can't I can't
um well and so then then that's what
changed my mind that's what that's what
changed my mind if a woman has a
miscarriage should there be you think
there should be an investigation no
that's a natural thing that happens but
what if she like jumps on the ground and
kills the baby because then calls it a
miscarriage if there was intent that's
what all crimes are based upon intent
like like if you intentionally tried to
kill the baby you know then then the
state would probably have some
jurisdiction there but
you know like how would they know unless
they investigate yeah but it's just like
any other crime how do you know unless
you investigate I mean and they just
don't invest we're just not we're not
talking about like talk about precedent
we're not talking about uh creating an
entire system with all these exceptions
and everything we're talking about we
already have murder laws we already have
these laws and they're based upon intent
and basically saying that life begins at
conception and so the state's duty is to
protect that life well not all life you
kill mosquitoes
um but you're talking about yeah humans
or people persons um and the argument is
living tissue isn't necessarily a person
so like a sperm isn't a person an egg
isn't a person a sperm egg combo isn't
necessarily a person until I in my
opinion until it's thinking and has
feelings and emotions and has a sense of
self
um other than that it's just like
growing tissue yeah but with that I
agree I agree uh that's the argument of
like when life begins right
um but I mean I I you know I've had I
have six children and a newborn you know
is not very aware of themselves not not
when life begins Life Begins sperm is
alive eggs are alive it's always living
stuff but whether or not it's a person
whether or not it's murder depends on if
it's a person because if you kill a cow
you're not murdering it well it
consumption conception is where you know
the the sperm and the egg come together
and they begin to grow as a as a as one
if you will and I believe that that's
when life begins as far as I mean I get
I I I get but I don't want to get into
somatics you know yeah I think life
began it's already it's always living
yeah
but it's not about killing life I just
want to say you know personally I'm
pro-life but I'm extremely skeptical of
giving police officers more reasons to
arrest people how would you handle it as
as a governor what would be a punishment
like what would you do to to a woman
well we already have murder laws right
you know so that's life that's that's a
Life Center no not always
you know predominantly depending on the
severity of the of the charge the degree
there's there's third degree I think
there's even fourth degree in some
states right and and the laws you know
the laws are there for a as a deterrent
right I mean you know uh
there that's really what they're there
for they're they're a deterrent and so
uh this would be a deterrent for people
uh taking the problem is if you don't
enforce laws no one takes them seriously
and it wouldn't just be a deterrent if
you're enforcing well I think there's a
there's actually a much simpler uh
breakdown of what happens the end result
is a abortion clinics just cease to
exist the the uh overall the amount of
abortions that happen will drop to a
ridiculous ridiculously low amount
they'll still happen the state probably
won't be arresting and Prosecuting
doctors because they'll be done in
secret and there's a lot of problems
with that the left brings up but in
reality as much as the left wants to
create the scenario where like the
police show up and they're like your
doctor's been arrested that probably
will never happen extremely rare
something that people need to understand
is that people can go online and admit
to committing serious crimes and post
the evidence and the government still
doesn't go after them the reality to
this life to this country is that they
do not want you in jail they I mean
first of all we all know it's going out
with the woke left in these big cities
releasing people like crazy but there's
overcrowding the courts don't want to
deal with it I can't look I once got
arrested for skateboarding and the judge
was pissed I show up for court and he
and he puts his glass on he looks and
he's like what he said come on my doc is
full already and you get out of my
courtroom so what what really happens
with these laws is my prediction on if
they actually did criminalize abortion
Nationwide as as like a murder charge
Planned Parenthood clinics or just cease
to exist and it would not be that big of
an issue but you'd see miscarriages
Spike well I think I don't think so a
lot I really don't think so oh yeah I
think I think babies
are shift everyone's going to stop
having sex like it's not a big deal it's
going to be a very very different thing
from the ground up and just make one law
and that'll change right I think we'll
realize okay it will have a massive
impact I mean look at uh there are
questions about when uh what can make
culture shaft for one the entire of this
this country just all of a sudden
decided that the the marijuana laws
didn't matter and people were just going
about breaking the law and making movies
about how funny it was so I'm not
convinced outright the culture would
change but Planned Parenthood and
abortion clinics would cease to exist
overnight if there was a nationwide ban
yeah and of course many of the left and
pro-choice they freak out about that
idea that's a reality there will still
be there it's not going to be back
alleys with coat hangers it's going to
be private underground facilities
the people who send stuff in the mail
little pills you take it there's no
trace of it there's going to be a huge
spike in miscarriage no there's not are
they just going to pretend like they're
not doing Secret abortions when they're
having and what you misunderstand is a
spike in miscarriages requires women to
report the miscarriages are happening
yeah so if you unreported stuff so if
you mean women so miscarriage won't
Spike because women will be inducing
abortion and not telling anybody so
abortions will go down some abortions
will remain miscarriages won't because
women are not going to report their
their their illegal abortions how is
that stopping the ethics of killing the
baby that doesn't change that one is the
state's not paying for it and two is
there is a law there in in place it is
it's a moral thing it stops elective
abortion I mean it it stops the
overwhelming majority of elective
abortions
a lot of that stuff is safer than taking
pills and killing them okay but hold on
look look you're getting me to argue for
him now
abortions would or the miscarriages
would spike is like I mean think okay
let me let me walk you through this
again a woman who has an indu who
induces an abortion illegally would not
report it right I don't know I don't
know so she'll go to the cops and be
like I broke the law arrest me is it
known that she's pregnant do her
neighbors know they're like you know she
was pregnant a week ago how would they
know if whiskey Whisperer if you're and
then the government's like we'll pay you
know we're making up scenarios also guys
it's important to note here Dave Portnoy
is going to be really pissed if this
goes through and then number two he's
like what you know a lot of people will
go to Canada and to Mexico like already
a lot of Mexicans a lot like a lot of
Americans are already going for for
their health care as well so that's
another component so the interesting
thing is is on the other side of this I
want to completely deregulate them the
medical uh industry uh interesting and
uh but why is abortion different because
it's life and if there was one thing
that the state is supposed to do it is
supposed to protect life and so I'm you
know I I lean very heavily on the
libertarian side absolutely so this is
not with abortion I think it's an
argument uh Ben Shapiro was made as well
that if if God if if you're libertarian
and you believe in very limited
government there is one thing that most
people believe government should do and
it's protect life that's right but then
it's the war machine like it's the
killer government's main job is to
protect life but it's also to kill and
to make murder legal so that they can
kill that's not something Libertarians
agree with my point is making is that
government's function Libertarians are
like the government should protect life
not not be actively taking it and most
Libertarians I think or Roman majority
are anti-war and don't want the US
involved in The Killing and and
Industrial military industrial complex
I'm raising my hand for that I mean
absolutely yeah so like if the
government's going to protect the life
of a baby by destroying the life of a
mother I just don't see the protection
hold on hold on we got to stop right
there the point that I brought up that
shape that I reiterated for Sheamus is
the mother will live and the baby will
live or the baby dies and the mother
will live you see you see the issue
you're talking about like no abortion
versus abortion right in an abortion
someone dies someone lives with no
abortion the mother suffers for a an
extended period assuming the mother is
suffering and then the baby is born but
both live that's that's the moral
argument that Sheamus made to me I'm not
saying I agree I think the idea that
more life is better is kind of erroneous
too because it's quality of life is
super important
yeah I guess so yeah but you don't take
life just because you're not going to
have good quality that's that's not
justification to take I'll just I'll
just shout out Sheamus again he made a
cartoon where there's a poor kid sitting
on his bed and he's like malnourished
and everything's grainy and gross and
Democrat Man shows up and then he's like
help Democrat man I'm hungry and poor
and he goes I'll save you and then
disappears and then reappears instantly
and then he goes what did you do when he
went he goes I went back 12 years to
convince your mother to get an abortion
and then the kid goes what no and then
just disappears like
it's an interesting point Sheamus makes
when when look
we hear a lot of really stupid arguments
from the left as to why abortion should
be allowed like kids are poor and I'm
like I'm pretty sure if you go to a poor
kid and say you should be dead they're
gonna be like no thank you yeah but I
think there are real challenges here and
mine mainly stems from the government
mandating someone's body be shared with
another person because I don't see a
moral way to resolve that I understand
the point Sheamus made that I brought up
several times so in in without running
in circles again let's jump to the next
story because this is not something we
can solve good conversation yeah but
it's good and it is really difficult but
let's jump to this story because it's
the apocalypse my friends the BBC
prepares secret scripts for possible use
in Winter blackouts wonderful scripts
set out how Corporation will reassure
public an event of major power loss well
if you live in a city as dense as London
and there's no power good luck I don't
know what they would do that's a that's
a massively dense City with no energy
how long until the water stops flowing
how long till there's no food everything
spoils in the dead of winter especially
when you can't heat your pipes the water
is going to of course create so much
damage all throughout you know the city
center it's absolutely mind-boggling to
understand how fragile our current
civilization is and what kind of a big
mess our politicians are getting us into
deliberately we have to understand these
are not policies that were just
accidentally created these were policies
that were fomented that were built that
were tested on other societies and are
being introduced right now all under the
umbrella of the great reset all under
the umbrella of taking care of the
environment meanwhile they are
deliberately limiting energy to people
so they could limit human potential this
is all a deliberate plan and people have
to really stand up for themselves
because if they don't the mess is
extremely serious it's already going to
hit everyone very very hard very soon I
just I just want to you know I point
this out whenever we talk about
blackouts but diabetics are at serious
risk because insulin needs to be
refrigerated if power goes out this is
this is seriously bad for people who are
diabetic you know they're going to lose
their lives now if it's in Wind are I
don't know how cold it gets in London
perhaps it will be cold enough outside
where they can get a cooler maybe they
can take snow or something and they can
yeah they can they can keep their
medicine
um uh their insulin at the right
temperature but even outside of that in
the winter when you can't heat your
homes yeah food's gonna food's gonna
spoil I suppose though in Winter you put
the food outside yeah it won't be as bad
but then you've hotter Summers every
year in London now I wonder though is
the reason they're concerned about
blackouts is because of heating your
home is is that the principal
consumption of energy yeah because they
don't have air conditioning in London it
reached stuff like this environmentalist
again this Global environmentalist uh I
don't know uh conspiracy almost but I
don't what's like what's behind it like
why are they saying that there's going
to be blackouts uh War I mean it's a
secret script right uh if possible but
is it is it war is it
um lack of energy yeah so with the war
in Russia you know Nordstrom they just
posted video from the nordstream attack
it's an attack now at this point 165
feet of the pipeline was blown off and
is missing that is not an accident that
is a huge chunk that's massive it's what
is that 165 fees that half a football
field yeah yeah that makes her have I
don't know more than half yeah more than
half so it says 300 feet right 100 yards
yeah like 70 60 feet no no no it's less
than half would you say 100 165. okay
more than enough half a football and was
it only one spot I thought it was or you
know I think they're a couple different
well they they uh maybe the the hits
were in different spots and then caused
it to fall off or whatever didn't know
what they hit it with no well we don't I
mean they wonder if they lined it with
Nano thermite and we know you did this
we know you did this why would Putin
blow up his own pipeline yeah it makes
no sense so they cut off uh the flow
into Europe Russia does Russia starts
you know uh oh now we've got this report
which I I've only seen it from South uh
South uh African sources but you were
mentioning the search that they uh Saudi
Arabia wants to join brics what's the
ramosa ramaphosa is that um yeah he's
the current president so you saw that
story is that true
um my family at chat had it going on in
the WhatsApp forever ago but that he's
saying Saudi Arabia wants to join bricks
yeah like like in the recent past yes
yes so apparently he posted on social
media saying this is going to happen if
that happens that is apocalyptic already
the Saudis are cutting oil production
Russia is a part of OPEC plus this means
that they're going to keep being able to
sell gas at a premium it's going to sell
to China China is going to sell to
Europe Europe is getting strangled out
come winter
we already saw the videos of Italy of
cafes in Italy Candlelight cash
transactions sorry when remember when uh
Texas got so cold that it and the
because of the energy or the power went
out and all of that that happened in
Texas I mean that's Texas we're talking
about London here we're talking about a
lot colder and the Mayhem that it caused
in Texas was
you know they're still they're still
recovering from that is the war worth it
it's a lot of you know the policies that
they've been laying forward that has
been deliberately denying people energy
and this is not a problem that's only
going to be around for the next few
months this is a problem that's going to
be around for the next few years uh the
telegraph is reporting that the National
Grid warns of a three-year energy crisis
as a National Emergency it is something
that that they cannot get away from they
just started to announce that they're
going to be fracking inside of the
United Kingdom but but energy is key to
human success to human prosperity and
again there is an agenda to limit that
specifically in in Ukraine right now
one-third of the power stations have
been destroyed as the World Health
Organization is of course warning about
a brutal winter ahead there's going to
be a lot of ramifications because of the
foreign policy because of the domestic
policy that has led us to this age where
we're literally going back to the Stone
Age why are we doing this well all in
the name of helping the environment it
and it's not helping the environment
it's not helping anyone we're just
literally buying uh you know patched
over gassed from Russia to China that
they're just shipping to to Europe right
now which is only making sure that
people lose more of their money and
can't afford to even live and and afford
a basic lifestyle so let me let me ask
you uh Ammon you guys you've been
ranching for a long time you've got
animals do you have more than cattle
you've probably got oh yeah but you know
of course horses and
all the chickens and that but mostly you
know cattle is where we make our money
off of them if the apocalypse happened
right now would your family be all right
yeah we'd be fine totally fine yeah
would you would you even notice like I
mean obviously you notice in the news
but like would it impact your your daily
food consumption is I mean Amazon
wouldn't show up you know yeah so
there'd be that of course we would be
affected but we would have food you know
we'd have supplies what do you do about
toilet paper that's why everybody lost
their minds and started fighting in this
in supermarkets for days
nice smooth Rock a relief like a big
leaf or something like that right yeah
yeah but uh no but in all seriousness I
ask because
um it's funny I mean I think people in
London would start eating each other
within a few days yeah I'm okay
realistically within like a week or so
so we might just look at London what's
going on over there well in Idaho good
old conservative Idaho there's the
Democrats there along with the uh
several establishment Republicans
they're trying to remove five dams uh
hydropower that's a primary source of of
energy trying to get rid of that trying
to get rid of them why for the salmon
they believe that the Salmon's got a
good but this is green energy this is
exactly what they wanted none of them
makes sense well it makes sense if you
if their goal is to get rid of people
and to reduce population that's the only
way it makes sense right I said it many
many times you're exactly right
everything they do look The Conspiracy
Theory as I mentioned would be the
intent to reduce population we know Bill
Gates has given speeches on reducing
population growth so we know he's he's
concerned about there being too many
people
if you look at everything they do take
intent out of it don't think conspiracy
just say hey all those things result in
less people
that's exactly right telling the
Netherlands to stop farming when there's
a food shortage looming shutting down
power plants when there's an energy
crisis telling Sri Lanka to get rid of
fertilizers well that's exactly right
it's all that's why I say it stinks of
that Global Environmental movement and
it's it's a deep delegation agenda this
is the problem with global
environmentalism is if they want to stop
oil production because it's dirty so
then we run out of electricity people
get desperate they go to war nuclear
bombs go off create a nuclear winter
with three years of no sunlight all the
Farms go dead talk about destroying the
environment environmentalists nuclear
war is the worst thing for the
environment that could possibly happen
right now next to an asteroid but pieces
are dangerous peace is dangerous didn't
you see that at some point you just got
to burn the coal and then recapture the
carbon well I got to correct you and
they're not just trying to get rid of
oil they're just buying it from Saudi
Arabia instead of domestically exploring
and and getting it out of the ground
here and importing it or they're doing
it from China just like they're doing in
Europe and that confirms uh the South
African president's cereal ramaphoso did
say this is from seven hours ago the
Crown Prince of Saudi Arabia did Express
Saudi Arabia's desire to be part of
bricks
that's from en.trend.az and then I also
saw that bricks expects Egypt Saudi
Arabia and turkey to join the group so
what would that be then Egypt turkey and
Saudi Arabia yeah
it'll be bricks plus
with the letters but I mean that's
turkey is Russia's Outlet into the
Mediterranean so that makes sense there
Egypt no NATO Saudi Arabia is just
they're protecting the Suez Canal they
want that trade route into the
Mediterranean where is the food in the
first nuke land because I'm chilling you
know I don't think it'll happen but
it'll be an air burst if it did well
yeah I know of course but like over what
city
no think false flag first not Kiev
absolutely not I I think why not Kiev
though
um too much civilian population I know
it's shocking off yeah but that's that's
that's a lot of death I think it's gonna
happen the entire population there's a
lot of military uh equipment and a lot
of uh military infrastructure in car
keys Kev and Martin car key were like
historically important to the Russian
the Russian people is there not a thing
yeah there's a lot of history there yes
there's a lot of blood there there's a
lot of stuff ring there there's a lot of
the capital of Russia like hundreds of
years ago or something that's that's
what I was asking about yeah sure yeah I
think so there you go uh but I don't
think I think I think Putin wants the
Don bass region to connect to Crimea he
wants to control more of the Black Sea
yeah so
well yeah I don't think he wants a
destruction of the world that's for sure
now who does we live here right you know
that's why I always find super villains
funny it's like I'm going to destroy the
planet it's like okay you live here dude
I think another possibility is that he
might just go to the Black Sea and just
explode something there as a show of
force as a show of power I think that's
also one possibility just to be like
look what I could do let me let's let's
negotiate uh so again lots of
negotiations lots of uh you know it's a
big chess game uh geopolitically that's
unfolding right now but uh I I don't see
Kiev I see a major key piece of uh the
war machine being affected here and I
think also as you mentioned before
there's a big possibility of a false
flag attack uh since of course there's
even U.S made nuclear weapons that have
gone missing so there's there's also a
lot of russian-made nuclear weapons that
gone that that were disappeared and are
missing so so what a big potential here
for for someone a bad actor to come in
and to create a lot of chaos that they
would benefit off of what if he nukes
like just sends like 100 100 nukes right
into Antarctica just just like Mars The
Martian oh no the thing about he did it
Antarctica is that the ice is all on a
land mass so that it actually would
raise ocean levels if the Ice broke off
and went to the water what if he just
went like full comic book villain was
like you know I'm not going to lose so I
won't nugu I'll nuke Antarctica and then
like oh no and there's no defensive
capabilities there so you know what do
you do
I mean it is kind of silly but there's
things like that you gotta think outside
the box he could say okay I won't nuke
you you can't retaliate against me but I
can hit the ice caps dude I watched the
nuclear winner you gotta watch a video
on nuclear winter because what happens
is oh yeah the nukes go off black clouds
over the everything for three years and
then it just covers the entire planet
yeah and the radiation is there for
hundreds of thousands of years
like unless they plan on going
underground with canned food for three
years and then coming back up and being
the ruler of a dead Planet I don't
understand the methodology bro Raven
Rock like I I look I wouldn't be
surprised if they have underground Farms
oh yeah probably they do absolutely yeah
um I think we need to appeal to
zielinski right now because he's the guy
that will listen to the America like
he's a he's an actor he's an Entertainer
he likes being loved he's I don't think
he's a horrible guy like At first I
wanted to hate him because of his but
like the position come on he's a puppet
president but like at the same time it's
it's in his lap if he wants to negotiate
with Putin right now no it isn't the
only person on Earth that can make this
happen is Vladimir
who else could do could start the
negotiations though because it's up to
him the United States of NATO you could
say that that Biden and Putin could do
it today also the European Union passed
the law that allows Ukrainian soldiers
to be trained in Europe uh and they will
be trained specifically in Poland and in
Germany and and again a lot of people
don't realize this proxy conflict could
last a very long time it could last 10
years it could last 20 years when we
look at these kind of sectarian
conflicts with you know the borders so
close to each other they escalate very
quickly they de-escalate very slowly and
the conflict is always going to be there
so this is something that's going to be
a hotbed for a lot of trouble for the
future so you know again negotiations
peace deals being able to come together
no one is going to be fully happy but
but I think we should still push for
them two coming together but the United
States NATO has to be a part of those
conversations because they're the ones
fueling this war there are the ones
financing this war they're the ones
making this war possible and that's why
they need to be at the table they need
to negotiate because if zielinski went
off on his own and was like I'm going to
negotiate you think NATO would have him
removed from Power well they were very
close to having negotiations they were
very close to zielinski and Pooh and
even coming together they had a meeting
they had a date that the two people were
supposed to come together and then
Western leaders came to zielinski said
no you're not going to meet with Putin
no you're not going to negotiate with
them no you're not going to have any
kind of Peace deals here and zelinski
said okay here's what I think would
happen if zelenski came out right now
and gave a speech and he said I'm going
to meet with Vladimir Putin to negotiate
an end of this conflict for the sake of
preserving the world and preventing
World War III half an hour would go by
and CNN would go breaking news zielinski
was killed in a car bomb it was Putin
who did it exploiting the fact that he
was trying to negotiate peace showing
just how evil he really was the new
second in command vice president has
taken over is even more war hawkish and
then it's going to cut to it guys and be
like I love America and that's there you
go that's my prediction or they could
just use the CGI hologram version of
them you know who knows there's a lot of
different possibilities but there's a
lot of psyops there's a lot of
disinformation there's a lot of
propaganda but at the end of the day
there's a lot of Life loss a lot of
innocent people are getting screwed over
or getting hurt we need to stop that
immediately and sadly all we have are
neocon warmongering bloodthirsty
warhawks who are saying more war more
death more destruction that to me is
absolutely insane and stupid and
literally is risking the existence of
our civilization why what's the end goal
what's the objective is it really
risking the civilization absolutely if
when they've got underground bunkers
like Raven Rock and mount weather and
that's just the ones we know about okay
sorry if the benefit of the 0.001 and
there's no exactly the people who have
their finger on the button are like I
don't care what happens I'll be fine
it'd be a new civilization our
civilization would be there's a limited
space station well I live in a big Space
Station underground I used to I have a
friend Zach router who who says uh that
Civilization is the fall of this
civilization is falling in I'm like well
no no it's this one particular he would
say that Civilization is the downfall of
humanity what we've done and I'm
thinking it's this civilization that's
on the back of oil that's obsessed with
like non-reproducible energy sources and
and food consumption that is that's
causing it yeah because I think if we
lived in harmony with nature if we were
getting energy out of the vacuum that we
could subsist if we were like you know
creating life and then consuming that as
opposed to just eating what's already
there
um so you're talking about finding a way
to harness Zero Point Energy yeah
exactly like the vibration of the vacuum
and stuff like that
um but I don't know enough about it but
but I've read a bit about it now I think
it's it's interesting I mean Fusion is
going to be huge but I'm not con against
that there are some people who have
argued that fossil fuels they're they're
not necessarily uh as funded as we think
and that they're constantly in a state
of production it's it's not dinosaurs
it's algae that gets compressed and
they've actually synthesized petroleum
this way that's so cool but I don't have
it but I think I think the real issue
for these people clearly is
energy dense resources like uh petroleum
results in more human beings and too
many human beings means you lose control
of the system right and if everybody had
their own energy source then you'd have
even more exponential exponential growth
of humans which could become an even now
imagine how much how much prosperous
Humanity would be if we had free energy
we would need to make moves fast because
if we get too many people on earth with
unlimited energy they'll blow each other
up I mean if we have free energy we can
just make space stations and leave and
go colonize the universe if we don't
have the technology like produce food
and water out of the vacuum then the
energy is useless it's just going to
make people get hot and blow people up
it's all about just converting into
their I mean everything is Just Energy
you got to convert it and mash things
together and structure it properly it's
it's still sci-fi doesn't mean it's not
going to happen but our civilization is
on the back of like a non-renewable
resource that it needs to seek out in
mind like you're saying they want mining
rates because they want those
non-renewables and uh and that would end
energy source that's that's renewable
an energy source well like
hydroelectricity
so aren't there components in
hydroelectric dams that have to be
replaced and repaired yeah renewable is
a it doesn't mean that it lasts forever
100 so we're still gonna have to mine
and search for minerals to make those
energy sources yeah you probably have
like one thousandth of the mining would
be nice if you had stuff like that or
like why one power like the amount I I
think you're making a lot of assumptions
because you don't pick it up a number I
mean you know propaganda terms right
a ton of oil
to make to run yeah they don't they
lubricants they cost more than than the
power would cost I don't know much about
so wind turbines have an extremely low
energy return on energy investment it's
like 0.4 I mean it I think it it might
be above one but it might be like 1.4
whereas like petroleum is like 30 and
nuclear power is like 50. so that that
means for every for every calorie you
put it you put you put an investment you
get X output nuclear is the best yeah I
believe Fusion is pretty regenerative
and fusion is I think the absolute best
we have so far but petroleum is just
it's massive it's easy to get I think I
think if the government was had been out
of the way for the last 30 years when it
come to energy meaning stop subsidizing
stop regulating stop controlling that we
would have already found a much better
way to create energy but because of the
government's regulations controls I mean
nuclear nuclear energy is is about as
efficient as you're going to get uh as
far as what we have developed in in
technology today but the governments
won't let us use it on the scale that we
should be using it
um right so but if the government was
out of the way and there was
deregulation if you will and I know
that's a scary word for a lot of people
and they were not subsidizing I believe
we would have a lot of answers already
when it comes to energy yeah yeah I
think so too I think it's intentionally
controlling the the output the valve
because they don't want too many people
yeah Bingo you you if nuclear energy was
the norm the energy return is higher
than petroleum so you look at that map
on another map the chart showing
population and then petroleum
skyrockets within the span of like one
generation it's insane we went from
having around 500 million people on this
planet for hundreds of years to billions
and it's because of Technology the
machinery for plants uh making you know
for farming as well as the ease easy
access of energy we upgrade from
petroleum to nuclear which is an even
better return and it's going to be
another exponential massive increase and
I'm all for it just build spaceships and
let's go send those spaceships out you
know put a bunch of people on them and
bye-bye I think
every person and don't quote me on this
but I'm pretty sure I'm pretty close
every person in Idaho can have like 22
acres to themselves
you know you know not that we want that
that people to come to Idaho but yeah
please don't uh yeah but uh please don't
you know and Nevada's even Nevada is
like 88 acres or something like that
well the interesting thing is we're
terraforming Vegas
because here's how it works Vegas is a
desert
people fly there and when those planes
come it brings water and human waste
from other cities and then people land
and they you know take their dumps and
their Beeps in Vegas all of that stays
there so we're bringing Mass amounts of
moisture in our own waste not right I
don't know about human fertilizer I
don't think they've met but but it is
creating it is bringing moisture then
also when they ship food in to feed all
these people that creates more moisture
so now I was reading how there's clouds
and there's grass growing they brought
in grass for houses because people like
it that's retaining moisture we're
basically it's a man-made man-made
terraforming of of uh the desert yeah
yeah Lake Meadville it's drying up quick
but they're but they're going to keep
shipping the water in yeah they're not
going to let it you know collapse it's
crazy it's crazy I yeah it's it's it
makes you wonder what they're going to
do you know how they might so my dad's
Ranch is like 20 miles well was 20 miles
just north of Lake Mead the very typical
Mead and now it's like 35 miles so wow
do you know that that old city that
reappeared what it was called St Thomas
yes yeah yeah I went there under the
under the Lake Mead yeah and then when
it dried up all of a sudden the
foundations and everything appeared and
people started going out and taking
pictures of and stuff I got to go there
and they found all those dead bodies
from them really yeah they found a whole
bunch
it makes sense because they were out of
Vegas for so long that's right yeah it's
crazy walking through the desert because
there's like plants everywhere and you
can't tell but there's boat parts
because people were you know the bottom
right and now it's all dried up now and
like it came back for a while but it's
once it's down way down way down it's
down further it came up a little bit and
then went way down it's all that global
warming you know bringing the end of the
end is not a lot of that's going to
California not just Vegas yeah they're
wiping a lot of it to Southern
California oh the lake need water
I think the bulk of it is actually going
to you know California it is yeah
interesting water rights uh that's the
guy who was it Michael burry the guy who
the big short I don't know if you saw
that movie where he he's he like oh
right said hey the 2008 uh housing
crisis is coming he was the one that
figured it out he says water's the next
big investment I remember him yeah so
he's investing in like food transport
and stuff like that
but again if we if we would get the
government out of the way we would
figure out a way to you know to re renew
water because moisture doesn't leave the
atmosphere I mean it doesn't so you just
it just goes different places and it has
to be used in a different way or or
benefited in a different way so we would
find ways to to you know either get the
salt out of the ocean or whatever it
might be yeah I'm concerned with getting
the government out of the way completely
because of like Nestle buying up water
rights and land like corporations
becoming the new government if we don't
have antitrust so the lessons that's
what California is basically the reason
all that water's been taken up in
California is for almonds number one and
then also a lot of the other water being
bottled up Vanessa which is a smaller a
smaller portion of it but still
significant the government protects
Nestle and allows them to do that
correct yeah correct yeah well so and
yeah and the other you know like not to
build on that too much because it'd be
boring to talk about but like the the
courts are where like if someone's
rights are violated we need the courts
to go to and try to work it out but what
we don't need is the government going in
and doing all these uh preventive you
know laws that actually make it so that
we can't use the natural resources we
can't be free if if Nestle is like you
know putting toxic waste inside in in
into the rivers or whatever they might
be doing then the courts are there for
the people to say look we're going to
take Nestle to to court we're going to
sue them and stop them from this but for
the government to come in and like say
we're going to regulate and control the
entire process so no one benefits I I
think I think that's where we where
we've gone wrong
we're gonna go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel hit the notification Bell and
share this show with your friends be the
notification you want to see in the
world YouTube isn't notifying everybody
the show goes out now some people are
like why would you need a notification
if you're going to watch show anyway
because some people they they're not
regular viewers and if they're not
getting notifications it means they're
not going to watch the show so if you
guys share the video the URL posted on
Facebook Twitter or wherever you can
then you are the notification and the
censorship will be less effective but
also go to timcast.com become a member
we have a members only show coming up at
11 PM should be fun and you also don't
want to miss this week's cast Castle
episode with special guest stars rusty
cage and Blair white let's read some
super chats all right
neglectable sausage says step one claim
abortion is murder step two continue to
pay IRS government to fund it step three
don't try to criminalize it step four
cowardice complete I don't know if step
four works but I get the point you're
trying to make
all right collisionikov says the Dems
are only just now switching parties
because for most people they got a burn
to learn the blue pill is the reddest
pill
yeah a lot of people voted for Biden
because they weren't paying attention
but now we you guys see that video of
them booing Jill Biden at the it was the
Eagles game I think no no I didn't hear
the booze I had I just saw a clip I saw
them it was crazy they were they were
booing and yelling F you know F Joe
Biden yeah and Jill's just like singing
along and like she's she's from just
outside of Philly I guess so this is
deep blue Philly booing Biden it's gonna
be crazy in in the next couple weeks man
what are we like 20 days out or
something like that is it 20 days 21
days he's got to take 21 possibility
this whole like we're gonna have a big
party
their fault that's the reason it's bad
it's over there like just take some
responsibility I think to win the hearts
of the people back but I don't know if
you can and beef liver Tim go for you
you want to get a bunch of beef liver
damn right why beef liver what about
foie gras why beef liver I've been
screaming about this for like ever it's
like the healthiest organ you get this
guy this guy was on this show talking
about how we gotta get rid of the seed
oils and was eating a Big Mac I don't
know what you're talking about that is a
Blasphemous Mr mayonnaise is sucking
down high fructose corn syrup seed oil
Drinker you this is actually funny
because I was like Luke mayonnaise
doesn't have sugar and I was screaming I
was like yes it does you mayonnaise eat
her but the mayonnaise that I normally
buy from the store there's no sugar in
it but then we're at we're at Sheets and
I had a packet of mayonnaise and I
looked at it had corn syrup in it and I
was like what it's a corn syrup in my
mayonnaise that's disgusting and it did
ketchup and it's in bread it's
everywhere you got it you got it was it
high there's a reason we were at the
supermarket I was screaming at the top
of my lungs inside of the supermarket
you have to that's the way to do it well
so we went we went to Mom's and Luke was
talking as loud as possible to make sure
everyone could hear him talk about it he
was like why is there seed oils in this
one he's like looking around to make
sure everybody's hearing him you know
they've renamed high fructose corn
there's a depopulation agenda of course
sterilize you look out for glucose
fructose as an ingredient because that's
what they're calling high fructose
they're renaming it yeah it's a Rebrand
it's a Rebrand
all right
let's grab some super chats
John Hay says Tim I make miniature
cameras for a private investigation firm
these things would be great for
journalists want to pitch in for a
change interested uh what's what's your
company how do you find them maybe it's
something project Veritas could be into
you know oh yeah I'm sure yeah
all right what do we got here
I am says yay did an interview with
Kanye West did an interview with Chris
Cuomo last night while he was on the way
to meet the CEO of parlor Millennial
influencers are making cultural moves
that's cool I'm glad you know good for
for Kanye I do think it's funny that
Kanye says this stuff about like a
Jewish Mafia and now I'm just like you
know okay Kanye but now there's memes of
Kanye Elon and Trump together and I'm
like do people realize that Kanye doing
this is bad for Republicans because he's
saying these things about Jewish people
that people don't like you know what I
mean yeah I didn't think it's I think I
do think it's fair to point out though I
don't know what Kanye's trying to say if
he thinks there's like a secret
conspiracy he's wrong but look there's
an Italian mafia like that's the thing
that they refer to like the mob it's
Italian if you point out that there's a
like if there's an organization of 50
people and they're Jewish would you not
call them the Jewish Mafia you know what
I mean you know I think a problem Kanye
is making is saying because his great
ancestors were Jewish this is the
argument that he's allowed to say
inflammatory things about them like it's
not a justification to be cruel or to be
wrong to say like erratic and you know
you gotta
it doesn't matter who your ancestors
were you got to take responsibility for
yourself yeah you can't make gross
generalizations be specific you know all
right grafty says oh my word buck buck
the best episode number eight I have not
laughed at media like that in a long
time being inundated with views
resolution dropped some but not choppy
surge thumbs up so that's a reference to
cast Castle episode eight which
um
uh was directed by Blair white uh so
direct all your complaints to Blair no
I'm kidding uh but Blair was involved
and uh helped with a lot of the jokes
they're really funny and what we're
trying to do what we want to do with
cast Castle is basically it's a hybrid
of comedy and and and commentary so we
can mock what the modern goings-on in
our own way you know you get the point
so that's why we did the cast Castle
Civil War Arc with like the election
where Ian's running for Union president
and then this one uh I'm gonna give you
the quick gist of the trailer for The
episode is
really simply someone is worried they're
going to be fired for harassment and so
they adopt identities which prevent them
from being fired and then you know you
should watch it rusty cage is in it and
it is dependently absurd yeah so uh I
think it did go up it went up a little
late today but it is what it is we're
really excited to get Blair involved as
well that was so awesome thank you Blair
for coming out and Rusty
all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim
no spoilers but that cat fight got me
good I also enjoy when someone pushes an
Oreo into my mouth Luke milkers are
bigger than ever imagined so definitely
become a member and watch the latest
episode of cast Castle because we're
gonna get medium matters writing but as
I imagine because we had we had good fun
I I stopped I I was there for the
filming of it but I haven't actually
watched the full thing so that's good I
watched before yeah worth it oh man I'm
nervous all right
Sean says yay is the next Target of the
Alex Jones president the left and Dems
have weaponized the courts system to
silence dissent this will never be used
against them only the right will suffer
from this
sounds about right well there's one
simple a solution just do and say
whatever the left tells you and you have
to worry about it right just bend the
knee and be subservient and what have
you got to lose after that apparently
nothing because you'll owe nothing but
you'll be happy so they say whatever
they say is Happy yep
all right unashamed truth says I want to
know Ammon how can idahoans save Idaho
oh man that's a loaded question yeah
kind of is tough huh yeah I want to put
in that to someone that grew up in Ada
County for a long period of my life it's
important for me so I wasn't your answer
is it true there's lots of potatoes in
Idaho yeah yeah it is true uh there's a
lot of other crops too agriculture is
the number one industry tonight for sure
by far which is awesome but is is it
just a stereotype from the commercials
Idaho obviously yeah I mean
we definitely produce a lot of potatoes
but we're not the number one producer I
don't know in the United States so uh
probably California we do a lot of wheat
I don't know who is but I heard that the
other day so uh I don't know how true
that is but I think it's funny is we
don't even we don't even eat all the
potatoes that we grow in Idaho they're
most of them are shipped out so all the
potential we get in Idaho are not from
Idaho in the first place yeah I grew I
grew potatoes in my garden this year
yeah yeah it turned out and we'd grow a
lot of corn a lot of wheat so back to
the question
um well
uh we we've kind of addressed the
federal land issues that we have federal
land control right and we can't even pay
our own bills unless we get that
straightened out but but really it comes
down to the left again invading Idaho
like coming in completely changing our
culture changing our laws all of that
that's what they're trying to do in
Idaho that's what they are doing they're
actually being successful at it yeah and
so you know I if there was one thing
that I think would get the Liberals to
leave is end the welfares and the
welfare in Idaho uh they'll be going to
these other states and and uh you know
getting on welfare there rather than
coming here because we know what is
happening they're coming here getting on
welfare and then they're like almost
full-time active and trying to turn our
state upside down so uh you know uh but
all right so that's one thing looks like
Idaho is the leading potato producer
2021 from statista.com followed by
Washington 10 in Wisconsin okay all
right William now I know William tresh
says I'm a corporate attorney generally
compensatory damages are not taxed as
income but psychological emotional
defamation and similar damages are
interesting and well there you go some
lawyers like how hurt were you more hurt
you were more you were probably really
hurt on a scale of nine to ten what's
your pain level and say 10.
all right and your pain Andrew Rowland
says Tim in response to you saying
Republicans will do nothing I rather I'd
rather have a government that does
nothing than a government that does
everything to take away rights agreed
absolutely absolutely amen beep boop
says breaking news Sheamus seen floating
into the sky sign of the rapture you
know that did happen is that where
Sheamus went you know he was on the show
one day and the next day I saw him naked
and just floating into the sky I thought
he was going to Mars
and maybe he did there you go he seems
more like a Uranus type of person yeah
he does just my own person he loves
those gas giants
let's see what we got Roscoe says we
shouldn't trust anyone switching sides
to Republican it's like the dude that
got in the woman's Lifeboat on the
Titanic no I completely disagree take
the wins take what you can get and trust
but verify you know if someone like a
lot of people are ragging on Tulsi
because she endorsed Biden but now she's
come out she's endorsed Carrie Lake and
uh Don balduck and I'm like take it
there are going to be Independents who
come with Tulsi and give you votes you
will gain power from this like you will
get political power from us so it's a
good thing there you go
whatever
Let's see we got here
darun albane says we need loser pays
laws to stop lafair I agree
loser pays
like the loser
pays oh so if someone Sues and they lose
they have to pay absolutely I mean
that's basically how it goes you sue for
damages and you have to pay for they
have to pay are you sue for our court
costs you know it's already like that
yeah yeah
Emily Payton says goats are better than
cows hands down yeah we were thinking
about getting a cow but we were told
they produce like eight to ten gallons
of milk per day is that true
Well yeah if you have a like a Holstein
or something you don't have to go they
don't have to be producing milk is that
what you were going to get them for
those for them yeah like you know not to
kill and eat but to have milk on here
you're gonna have a milk cow yeah they
can produce up to 12 gallons a day yeah
12. yeah if they're like without any
kind of like injections we need a cow I
don't know like what the Organics I
should know it's probably a little less
but uh they still produce a lot of milk
so what do you think goats or cows what
do you got uh goats will do like you
know probably a a gallon gallon and a
half wow a gallon a day with a good yeah
because twice a day sometimes three
times a day yeah and so they'll yeah
they'll produce probably a gallon and a
half a day do you have a preference cow
or goat well goat cows have three
stomachs so their milk is very even and
it's that's why we use cows for milk
goats don't so like if they eat a weed
or something oh no
and it has a you know so you I it can be
really really good and it's really good
for you like babies who are lactose
intolerant can usually handle goat's
milk yeah and so it's really good for
you so yeah go for adults that's awesome
but and I heard that they're fattier so
if you want to make cheese and stuff
goat is better goats you know unless
there's certain like like a a jersey uh
will will produce more in in cows
they'll produce more uh cream than like
a Holstein so but goats are great but
there's like smaller cows right they
don't produce as much
uh yeah I mean get a nice little small
Jersey that's great yeah but you know as
much people are like get goats and I'm
like yeah because you get you know one
goat and like you said the people are
advising maybe get two dwarf goats or
whatever but like cows are funny you
know they stand there all day like
whenever I drive past cows they're just
standing they're not doing anything is
that all they do they just stand there
yeah I mean you know it's funny they
just eat all day yeah I find it
entertaining so we have a chicken City I
don't know if you saw it I saw that yeah
they're they're I was reading on
Wikipedia it said humans find their
behavior entertaining and I was like
this is this is a verified confirmed so
if you were gonna advise a budding
Rancher what would be the first Ranch
animal or or group of them animals that
they should focus on well I mean it if
if you're doing it for food or you're
doing it for money that's that's what
okay that's a good that's the first
thing you gotta do for surviving the
apocalypse yeah for surviving well so
uh actually rabbits will produce more
meat in a years period of time than two
rabbits uh you know male and a female
rabbit will a buck and a doe will
produce more meat than a bull and a cow
uh but bovine in one year and they're
much easier to take care of but you
don't get enough fat from Rabbits
actually yeah that's true that's true so
you got to have you got to go kill like
a walrus or something or a well and then
get lots of fat from it so is there like
like a pig maybe like could you
supplicant could you uh supplement uh
the rabbit meat with like a fattier meat
like a big or something pork
um yeah pigs are like
you know they got skin like humans
almost so they're like susceptible to
like cold and heat and you know you
really gotta that take care of them
they're labor intensive and if you if
you I hear if you faint or fall into Pig
Pig's die they'll eat you yeah probably
so so like get it yeah get a uh if I was
to do it I would get you know chickens I
would have a goat goats and I would have
I would still have cows I'd still have
you know and then just have more they
can reproduce and
and that's a pretty good you know why
chickens are funny they're smart enough
not to drink water they crap in but not
smart enough not to crap in their water
and that's that you know so we have we
we had when we first got the chickens we
noticed this and someone sent us one of
the the the the the water chicken water
bins where it's got the little nozzles
they can Peck and I'm like it basically
solved the problem but man they just
crap where they stand you know yeah and
it's just everywhere so if you don't
like have it where they can drink water
without crapping it they'll just thirst
to that yeah they stop drinking it yeah
so I mean this is what was happening to
us it was annoying I'm like well why did
you even that we have we have the
brooders and the water setup is very
difficult for them to crap in they still
figured how to do it and the weirdest
thing is when you look at the plastic
like the see-through plastic on the
brooder somehow they crap up onto it and
like it's and you're like how did they
do that I get that metaphor where you're
like the World Elite think of us like
chickens because it must be so
frustrating to be like chickens all I
need is some fresh water quit why do
they and they are just too stupid to get
it because they're chickens they're
always going to be too stupid and is
that what people think about me is it
like he's just not gonna stop going to
the grocery store man he's just too
stupid all right let's read some more
Johnny generic says federal government
owns a huge amount of land in the west I
covered this in my blog blog spot Johnny
generic and uh we didn't pull it up but
it was on ammon's computer he showed
it's crazy
all right Jackson says the land is hard
Rocky scrubby and arid good for little
else than cattle grazing the tortoises
would enjoy the company down with BLM
both will do nicely
that's a good one
all right Brave New clown world says
amen Bundy is described as an American
anti-government militant on Wikipedia
it's a title I think we all strive for
uh but I I wouldn't I wouldn't say
that's that that's accurate No it's not
accurate it's it's you know Wikipedia
always just takes the most extreme
version of whatever they can paint you
as always anti-government people don't
the Roger Stone sorry Roger Stone's all
about like never defending yourself you
know just always going on the offense so
I'm not going to defend that title
you're like whatever I'll take it but uh
it's it's not accurate
all right Russell Miller says Hey crew
just recently subscribed on timcast the
after hours shows are hilarious Tim
Poole reading facts check that has
nothing to do with topic effing and I
was dying love you guys stay safe yeah
that was uh passobic Jack busovic posted
on Instagram about how
all of these people were saying that the
vaccines would stop transmission but now
you have the Pfizer executive who said
they didn't test for it there was a fact
check put on his his Instagram and when
you click it it says misleading context
because they didn't test for that and I
just yelled effing I actually sword and
like what does it have to do with
anything
but uh you know the the after hour shows
are always really fun so you want to
sign up at timcast.com we're gonna have
one of those coming up for you
all right DD Mega Dudu says the Bundy
story was one of the first stories that
red pilled me and was a flagrant example
of government corruption I wish you luck
in your race reach out to Jason Seiler
of the simple truth who moved there
recently I recently went to Waco
I went to the uh the Branch Davidian
compound got to uh look at the uh you
know read the history of it they have a
bunch of stuff there you can check out
and when you when you read about the
stuff you go you just
they do the government does dirty things
yeah and like look if there were
criminals who could get away with
committing a crime they would and so
when there are people in government who
commit crimes they will get away with it
and who's going there's no cops for the
cops yeah if you want to if you want to
commit a crime just become a politician
and I really wanted to ask you you know
what did you learn about government
infiltration from your experiences like
at the bunny ran yeah oh man so uh
we we actually did not find out that the
FBI was even in involved at the ranch uh
and until our trial two-year well it was
almost four years later when we're in
trial and we start to run into this like
this discovery and we started doing
cross-examination with the government
Witnesses and we find out that the FBI
was actually pushing and and in control
of this whole thing and that the they
tried to scrub that they were even
involved at all and we ended up
discovering that they were hiding over 3
800 files not documents files of EX
esculpatory evidence and we just blew it
all up like it was the FBI that was
behind all of this and it was the HRT
team the same team that went into Waco
the same team went into Ruby Ridge the
same team that killed my friend Lavoy
finicum and it was that same group of
government agents that were pushing all
the buttons at the Bundy Ranch was there
any agent provocateurs uh absolutely
they were they had what they called the
First Amendment team where they actually
went down among the people and were
trying to create dissent trying to you
know provoke the people uh there was all
of that was going on
so yeah I mean I could go you know I
could go on and on with that but yeah
and they actually had hired uh former
CIA agents to come in and to like for
Alias to run their Alias social media
accounts and all of that to try to get
the people to basically turn against us
because they they felt like if they
could get the people to turn against us
and that then they would justify the
violence that they were about ready to
use upon my family yeah I think they
were using the Bundy name because I
thought Ted Bundy and and I thought of
like Ruby Ridge and like Waco those are
the things that were going through my
mind whenever I heard about the Bundy
ranch right and they weren't like making
it they weren't clearing it up for me
nothing was being cleared up for me yep
all of that was going on at the little
Bundy Ranch in the middle of the desert
all right Elijah says Tim you've got it
backwards give the death penalty to the
rapist not the innocent child why kill
the child for the sins of its father we
wouldn't do that in any other case but I
have not made that argument my argument
is why should the government have the
right to mandate a woman have to share
her body and blood with another human
being
I just I I do not see an ethical line
there granted
there's like no middle ground on the
debate it's like it's a straight Spike
and you either fall on one side of the
other and it's very very difficult that
being said there's a new Middle Ground
forming because the left has become
pro-abortion outright where they're
arguing for abortion to the point of
birth where I'm just like okay well now
we're all against that yeah I don't know
and they're like you're right wing I
actually was I was on here debating with
a leftist as as pro-choice traditional
position which is like you know first
first trimester pre-viability but
post-viability not allowed in any
capacity and he's arguing with me like
I'm pro-life and Sheamus sitting here
not saying anything and I'm like the
pro-life guy is there like you're
arguing with me this is crazy they've
gone nuts on this stuff man but that's
that's ultimately what's happening
because this is what I said they thought
they got me because I said if I have to
vote between a Democrat who wants
abortion to the point of birth and a
pro-lifer who says banal abortion I vote
for the guy who's going to ban all
abortion because aborting a baby at nine
months gestation is insane yeah but like
what do you want me to do I'm not happy
about the the choice but if that's your
position I vote for not killing babies I
think I'd err on the other one because
letting them kill a baby trying to
control Society feels like centralizing
control of society sounds really
dangerous right now some people make
make some good points we we legislate
morality why where where we draw the
line on when it is murder is an
interesting point to be made and I think
that if a baby's been in the womb for uh
if the baby can survive outside the womb
then killing it I mean I think abortion
is wrong outright I think lighting is a
conception and I believe it is killing a
baby to abort it I think elective
abortion
man that's tough
I think abortion as an elective process
for contraceptive reasons I would akin
to murder
I'm not in the same position as most
pro-lifers
I don't know why that is but I would say
if the baby can survive on its own and
you kill it you are murdering the baby
the thin layer of Flesh between the
mother and the baby does not change the
fact the baby could survive if it were
to be removed from the mother so this
killing it serves no purpose
but Democrats tried passing a law to
Grant exceptions to allow this and I
think that's just Bonkers insane crazy
so who do you vote for who do you vote
for now you have actually have
Republicans saying okay we're going to
give exceptions on on the issues of rape
and I'm like well okay
all right I guess you know and Democrats
are like no no we don't want any we
don't want any restrictions at all and
I'm like well I'm not voting for that
yeah yeah they show their true colors
and really what their motives are they
really do
yeah
Thomas Scarlett says do you not get two
murder charges for killing a pregnant
woman in some states not all states but
in some states you would and that just
is weird isn't it in California
that if you like if a woman's pregnant
and you like crash into her car or
whatever negligently they charge you
with killing the baby sounds like it
you hear about that judge that uh I
guess this lady got pulled over for
going in the HOV lane and she's oh she
claimed that she was pregnant and he had
to agree with her that there was two you
know two people so he he had her fine
for not having a car seat
foreign
I mean I I think that's funny but I
think he should have just went oh you
got me oh geez precedent has been set
it's a life I agree thank you so much
ma'am just roll with that
okay gen Z says Ian is pure evil
okay
good and evil are very scary
it's not that bad
he's not pure you've only 87 good 13
evil yeah you know 13 it's it's you know
like a like a like a good uh delirium if
you're good all the time you're a zealot
because good is your own subjective idea
of what good is a good point no no I
think that's evil of course zealotry is
evil I think zealotry zealotry yeah
zealotry is typically like well blind
zealotry yeah to specify but like
yeah because you can be developed about
positive things like not being willing
to reason or listen I think is is the
banality of evil protecting your
ignorance I don't know sometimes you
gotta you gotta just go with what you
know is right
all right ajiro says Tim you guys keep
talking about Putin unleashing nukes
what about the US doing the same talk
about us
I don't see the U.S nuking Ukraine
that's where the war is happening and I
don't see the U.S launching a preemptive
nuclear strike on Russia although hey
maybe
I just don't think it's likely I think
the reality is that Putin needs to win
this war in Ukraine and nukes our path
to doing it um
the USA got a major military Alliance in
NATO I don't know you guys think the U.S
would nuke them first I don't think so
no
all right cam girl as soon as so let me
get this straight these people are
intentionally trying to reduce the
population and that is not grounds for
armed Revolt just let them kill me hey
Tim
um well first of all I'm not saying
intent and the interesting thing is this
this Falls in line with like this
Fallout narrative you have you ever
heard of the video game series Fallout I
don't it doesn't seem like it'd be up
your alley I haven't in the first
Fallout I think it might be one it might
be two you might know this yeah the
Super Mutant queen or king or whatever
first one the first one says we'll allow
you to live but we're gonna sterilize
you like we don't want to kill you and
harm you but we can't allow you to
procreate like that's one of the enemies
and you can be okay and then you live a
happy healthy life but you know they
sterilize you whatever you become a
mutant no well you can choose to right
that's one of the options one I heard
you guys talking about Fallout last time
one of the things the fall Universe gets
wrong is all the food in a real life
situation like you were saying pick up
moldy cheese you'd be lucky to find a
piece oh yeah it would be like 90 plus
percent of the population would just
starve out right away eating each other
but uh as you can even find something
someone to eat it'd be crazy because
people be irradiated as for armed Revolt
you are 20 days away from a red tsunami
where we may actually see some profound
changes so no no armed Revolt the the
opportunity right now is look Elon is
buying Twitter we may see a major shift
in the culture war that grants free
speech I mean things are looking really
good
don't don't ruin it now by you know
acting a fool now is the chance to just
walk with a smile on your face cast your
ballot get your friends to vote and then
when the Republicans come in I'm not
confident all the Republicans but I
think a handful Carrie Lake that's
really exciting to me in Arizona and if
you've got concerns about what's going
on in Arizona's government I think Cary
Lake's a really great option so get out
there and vote she swept the primary
let's see what happens
so
it's looking good we'll say that you
don't uh don't make mistakes when you're
winning
all right uh well I think we've gone a
little bit over so we'll just leave it
there if you haven't already please
smash the like button would you kindly
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends and become a
member at timcast.com because I assure
you if there was ever a cast Castle
episode you'd want to see it's going to
be this one with special guest stars
Blair white and Rusty Cage
it is it is Bonkers crazy one of the
craziest ones we've ever done I'm really
excited to watch it I I hope it came out
well
um I was involved a bit in the writing
and directing uh but we had a bunch of
people working on this one so it's
really exciting we've got some great
plans for the next one that's going to
be really offensive and if you listen to
the uncensored members only show you'll
have heard what the idea may have been
and so it's going to be really
disgusting and fun so uh check it out
over at timcast.com you can follow the
show at timcast IRL you can follow me at
timcast Ammon do you want to shout
anything out uh
I've got a a really uh detailed website
at votebundy.com people can donate there
they can donate there they can find out
what I'm all about there's lots of
videos I've dressed abortion I've
dressed the groomers I've I've addressed
you know a lot of hot topics there and
videos and yeah vote bundy.com
go subscribe to Twitter realm and Bundy
um yeah support me right on Idaho's
looking really good and we're we're
making a big impact there sounds good
thanks for coming on my YouTube channel
is youtube.com forward slash we are
change I'm very proud of the video I did
today about Russia the larger proxy war
the larger the newer strategy here check
that out and I will see you there on
youtube.com forward slash we are
changing you can follow me at Ian
Crossland on any social media there it
is behind me if you want to see how that
looks almond or Ammon almond I was like
it's not aemon it's not almond it's
Ammon that's right um it's real a Bundy
at Twitter correct it's just the a real
a and uh when people idahoans come and
check you out when is the election it's
November 8th and uh and uh yeah it's
it's a you can you know they're doing
the early ballot stuff already uh but
November 8th is when we all go down and
vote good talking to you man yep you too
yeah hey man Idaho in the chat I see a
lot of people here posting they're from
Idaho so you know what's going free man
stand up we will see you all over at
timcast.com at about 11 pm thanks for
hanging out cheers